bruno bartocetti bonjour bonjour
mais même avoir une vie merci d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france alors pour
commencer quel sont les derniers
éléments porter à votre connaissance sur
le déroulé des faits alors ce matin bien
sûr comme vous l'imaginez nous employons
activement à retrouver cet individu qui
a battu froid de morne notre notre
collègue notre policier
hier soir nous nous donnons tous les
moyens pour pour interpeller ce ce voyou
et je peux vous garantir que que nous
nous l'interpelleront et nous leur
remettrons à la justice avec bien sûr la
teinte d'une sanction extrêmement sévère
à l'endroit de ce criminel dans quel
contexte votre collègue at il été tué on
parle d'un contrôle lors d'un trafic de
drogue c'était une opération qui était
prévu c'était un flagrant délit que
parce que ça s'est passé alors au départ
c'est les collègues interviennent sur
sur des perturbateurs dans un des
quartiers un peu sensibles de même si
c'est le centre-ville de montpellier
on dirait un quartier plutôt sensible et
est pas dans cette cette intervention
qui ne tourne pas autour d'eux des
stupéfiants dans un premier temps bien
des rivières vers un contrôle de
stupéfiants car un individu
vraisemblablement en train de de deals
et a pris la fuite lors ce qui nous a
vus et mes collègues policiers l'ont
poursuivi très rapidement ce ce criminel
s'est retourné a fait feu sur sur les
policiers
et vous connaissez la suite a touché
mortellement marne un de mes collègues
on entendait
le ministre de l'intérieur parler de
guerre contre le trafic de drogue
il parlait des policiers aujourd'hui
comme des soldats qu'est ce que ça vous
évoque de la période que vous visez vous
savez nous sommes déjà aussi pris pour
cible comme des soldats dans le cadre
des attentats terroristes
douze policiers sont décédés un dans le
cadre des attentats terroristes on a 80
policiers qui sont morts en service
depuis 4 5 ans de nombreux blessés dans
nos rangs
alors nous sommes pas des guerriers à la
base à nous sommes là nous sommes
policiers nous sommes là pour sécuriser
la population et nous sommes pris pour
cible d'ailleurs sur un simple contrôle
même un simple différend familial se
retourner comme contre nous et nous
essuyons régulièrement des coups vous
avez dit me le policier parents qui sont
blessés en service on intervient tout
les 9 10 secondes en france c'est très
difficile de travailler dans ces
conditions nous attendons beaucoup bien
sûr beaucoup de notre gouvernement
ceci étant dit lorsqu'aujourd'hui vous
vous travaillez sur des trafics de
drogue
il faut savoir qu'il ya aussi un trafic
d'armes et ce dealer qui étaient là pour
vendre deux des stupéfiants était en
possession d'une arme il ya un trafic
d'armes également dansé dans ces
quartiers sensibles et c'est pour cette
raison que c'est très difficile pour
nous de travailler
c'est pour cette raison que au delà des
propos qu'a tenus hier notre ministre
l'intérieur et nous le rejoignons bien
évidemment une attendions de sa part un
geste fort c'est la population toute
entière à part les voyous et les
décérébrés bien sûr et certain certains
députés comme mélenchon qui n'hésite pas
à cela
ça me prend dans l'institution policière
est bien apparu vous avez la population
derrière nous pour nous soutenir dans
notre travail au quotidien
parce que le gouvernement ait
effectivement fait de la lutte contre le
trafic de drogue une priorité vous lui
disiez lutter contre le trafic de drogue
c'est aussi lutter contre le trafic
d'armes est ce qu'aujourd'hui vous êtes
suffisamment préparés formé équipé pour
faire face à des individus fortement
armés dans certains quartiers alors nous
sommes assez équipés pour interpeller
ces individus lorsque nous sommes je
vais employer le terme prédateur mais
lorsque vous êtes le
vous intervenez sur sur un simple
différend familial
on est pris pour cible et on
n'intervient pas sur sur toutes les
situations avec avec l'équipement de du
gipn et du raid
ceci étant il ya aussi un travail
portant de la justice alors on n'est pas
là pour opposer police justice et
remettre en cause la bonne volonté de
certains certains magistrats
mais ce qu'on se donne les moyens
vraiment en frace de de répondre
pénalement et sévèrement à l'endroit de
ces deux cd de ces voyous bien non il ya
la réponse n'est pas donné vous savez
lorsqu'un braqueurs et est traduit en
justice s'il est présenté à la cour
d'assises il peut prendre 15 en moyenne
il prend 10 12 ans lorsque c'est un
dealer ces deux ans alors qu'il est en
possession de stupéfiants et d'armes à
feu
donc à un moment donné il faut en france
se donner les moyens de sanctionner
sévèrement cd rom 1 ces voyous lorsque
parce que le président de la république
s'est déplacé à montpellier
il était en compagnie de son ministre à
l'intérieur ça aurait été important qui
se déplace avec ce le ministre la
justice pour voir dans quel état se
trouvent ces tribunaux donc je crois que
la réponse aujourd'hui est unanime on
attend de notre gouvernement une réponse
sauf forte à l'endroit de la sécurité de
nos concitoyens et des policiers et au
delà de toute toute réponse politique
sur du court terme à tous les élus de la
république m notre gouvernement doit se
donner une priorité sur ce phénomène là
et on doit protéger de notre police
alors à travers peut-être en équipements
supplémentaires mais surtout avec des
réponses pénales adaptées
merci beaucoup bruno bartocetti d'avoir
accepté notre invitation dans la
matinale de rtl france lampel vous êtes
délégué syndical unité sgp police grand
sud